حيث قرر قديروف الذي يجيد فنون
القتال والدفاع عن النفس معاقبة
اخطائه. عارضا عبر الانترنت صورا
التي صورها التليفزيون الروسي.
لعقوبات امريكية مغلظة وهو ممنوع
من السفر الى امريكا ايضا. لكن
الشرق الاوسط. يتم استقباله في
الدول العربية. وقبل كأس العالم
ذلك لم يمنعه من تطوير بلاده. بل
انه صار بطلا يشار له بالبنان في
وزير الرياضة سلام بك اسماعيلوف
بخوض مباراة ملاكمة معه. وقال
عشرة الاف مقاتل شيشاني بحسب بعض
التقارير. وضمهم الى قوات موسكو
عام الفين وثمانية عشر في روسيا
استقبل قديروف اللاعب المصري
وهو يقصد بذلك غزو اوكرانيا.
واضاف انه يمكنه حشد سبعين الف
انتظارنا زادت العقوبات التي
تنتج عنها. من طرائف قديروف.
سمحت له بارتداء خوذة. كغيره من
القادة الكبار يخضع قديروف
وانني للتضحية بحياتي من اجلك.
لكن لا يمكنني مشاهدة مقاتلينا
محمد صلاح الملقب بفخر العرب.
وقام بجولة معه في ارضية الملعب.
المراكز السكنية من القوميين
متعصبين. قديروف كان قد قال ان
واليسرى ان عليك ان تعمل برأسك.
ولان الوزير بدأ يصحح اخطاءه
فهل يكتفي قديروف بانجازاته في
بلاده ام انه يتجه للمشاركة في
ما يحدث والسماح لنا بانهاء كل
شيء. كما اردف انني رجل متواضع.
عملية ترميم مبنى وزارة الرياضة
المتهالك في جمهورية الشيشان.
وجاء النزال بعدما اعرب الزعيم
الشيشاني عن عدم رضاه بسبب تقدم
استدعى رمضان احد وزرائه الى
حلبة ملاكمة لمعاقبته على
قديروف خلال حوارنا جدالنا شرحت
له بلطف بقبضة يدي اليمنى
متطوع للقتال في اوكرانيا. وطلب
قدروف من بوتين عدم الالتفاف الى
روسيا ان تحافظ على امنها. وبعد
ما بدأت الحرب جهز جيشا مكونا من
الذين يموتون. كل هذه المفاوضات
لا طائل من ورائها. فكلما طال
بوتين اتخذ القرار الصائب.
وسننفذ اوامره مهما كانت الظروف.
الشيشانية يتقدمون بثقة في عمق
اوكرانيا. ويحررون خلال ذلك
على الارض الاوكرانية. وقال
رمضان ان مقاتلي القوات الخاصة
اوكرانيا. قبل بدء الروسي
لاوكرانيا. قال قاديروف ان من حق
فقد اطلق على قديروف لقب فتى
بوتين المدلل. موقفه من غزو
بوتين. وبسبب قوة العلاقة بين
فلاديمير بوتين ورمضان قديروف
اعلن قديروف عدة مرات في عدة
مناسبات انه يهب حياته دفاعا عن
رمضان قديروف هو الرئيس الاقرب
الى الزعيم الروسي فلاديمير
هنا في وقت ليس ببعيد. قديروف
والكرملين وفلاديمير بوتين.
موقع التواصل الاجتماعي فيسبوك.
صرح قائلا ان رئيس الشيشان وجنود
مرير من السلطات الروسية بسبب
الوضع في الشيشان. اشار الى ان
اقتصادية. في عام الفين وعشرة.
رئيس الوفد البريطاني لجماعة
يعودوا ويعملوا لصالح وطنهم او
يبقوا هناك لبقية حياتهم. نهضة
وفي عام الفين وتسعة قال قديروف
كل الامراء والاشخاص الذين كانوا
للبلاد بمباركة فلاديمير بوتين.
وما هي الا ايام حتى بدأ التغيير
الدفاع عن روسيا. واكد انه مستعد
للموت من اجل روسيا والرئيس
الشيشان جميعهم مستعدون للتضحية
من اجل الرئيس بوتين ومن اجل
هناك تغير واضح نحو الافضل في
الجمهوريات الشمالي القوقازية.
جود قال ان التغييرات التي حصلت
منذ اخر زيارة للمفوضية في عام
بوتين. ويعتبر واحدا من اكثر
الشخصيات قربا الى الكرملين. وقد
حقوق الانسان لوردد جود والذي قد
صرح سابقا انه يشعر بالحرج بشكل
روسيا وعن الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين. وكتب ذلك على صفحته على
في السلطات الشيشانية ليحكم
رمضان قبضته على البلاد باسرها.
الفين. كانت كبيرة للغاية للدرجة
التي ينسى فيها الشخص ما قد حصل
اوروبا والذين لم تتلطخ ايديهم
بالدماء لديهم خياران. اما ان
افرادا سابقين في تشكيلات مسلحة
غير شرعية. والذين هم الان في
مسالمة في روسيا. وفي غضون بضع
سنوات ستصبح اسرى واغنى الاماكن
وسبعة وافق البرلمان الشيشاني
على تعيين رمضان قديروف رئيسا
في العالم. ليعلن بذلك ان الحرب
قد انتهت بالفعل. وان ما تبقى لا
قديروف انه انتقم من الذي قتل
والده وسيقتل الذين وقفوا خلفه
يتجاوز مائة وخمسين لصا كما
وصفهم. يقصد المعارضين. وقال
واحدا واحدا. حتى وان يقتل او
يسجن هو بنفسه. وفي عام الفين
سيبني اكبر مسجد في اوروبا. وقال
ان الشيشان هي المكان الاكثر
زولي قديروف من السجن. وفي العام
ذاته خرج رمضان قديروف بانه
وخمسين رجلا مسلحا بالتوجه الى
مركز شرطة مدينة خسافيورت
واجبروا رجال الشرطة على الرضوخ
لهم تحت تهديد السلاح واخرجوا
من قبل الشرطة الداجستانية. فقام
رمضان قديروف ومعه حوالي مائة
القائد. في عام الفين واربعة تم
اغتيال رئيس الشيشان ووالد احمد
بالملاكمة. حتى انه التقى
بالملاكم العالمي من الوزن
المسلحة الروسية. وبعد الحرب.
رمضان اصبح السائق والحارس
الرياضية الفارهة والخناجر
الشيشانية ومشاركته في سباقات
للخيول وهوايته في ممارسة
الملاكمة. قديروف كان قد حصل على
كما يدعم تعدد الزوجات. وهو
مشهور بامتلاكه للسيارات
رتبة لواء في الحرس الوطني
الروسي عام الفين. قديروفي
قديروف وهناك بدأت قيادة رمضان.
ففي الفين وخمسة تم احتجاز اخته
احمد قديروف. وكان دائما يحاول
تقليد والده. كان شغوفا
الثقيل مايك تايزن. قاتل رمضان
قديروف الى جانب والده ضد القوات
الشخصي لوالده احمد قديروف. ويعد
رمضان من اتباع التيار الصوفي.
اسمه زلم خان. لكنه توفي في عام
الفين واربعة. في المدرسة كان
الرئيس الشيشاني السابق احمد
قديروف. ولد قديروف في الخامس من
قديروف او كما يقال بالعربية
رمضان بن احمد ال قدير. هو ابن
البنية مفتول العضلات ذو لحية
شقراء. ذكي ماكر. انتهج اقصر
الذي يدخل على بوتين بدون
استئذان. شاب مسلم شيشاني قوي
شخصا وكان قديروف دائما يسعى
للحصول على تقدير والده الامام
المصارعة. رمضان قديروف نتحدث
وللقصة بقية. رمضان احمدوفيتش
اكتوبر من عام الف وتسعمائة وستة
وسبعين. كان لرمضان اخ اكبر منه
الطرق ليصبح رئيس الشيشان الاول
وهو شاب صغير. هو الرئيس الاوحد
في العالم الذي يعاقب مسؤوليه
الفاسدين بجولة في حلبة
لواء. هو شيخ صوفي ملتحي يفدي
بوتين بحياته. هو الرئيس الوحيد
من حلبة المصارعة الى الحلبة
السياسية. وفي المعارك تجده في
الجندي الشرس لروسيا. وفتى بوتين
المدلل. الذي قال عنه بوتين يوما
انه الولد الذي لم انجب. رئيس
دولة برتبة مصارع وعسكري برتبة
مقدمة الصفوف. هو رجل ديني هادئ
ملتزم. ولكن الرقص هوايته.
قضايا خارجية واسلامية على وجه
الخصوص.